we've now been taking pretty seriously
for more than a year the topic of Donald
Trump's possible cognitive decline and
sort of fitness to be President of the
United States we recently had dr. John
Gartner psychiatrist from Johns Hopkins
Medical Center back on the program he
believes that Donald Trump is in some
combination of a pre dementia state
combined with some cognitive limitation
or disorder and possible personality
disorders we've been observing this kind
of disordered speech and disordered
thinking for a long time now
ignorance combined with very confused
attacks on people and things that don't
really seem to make sense for a normal
adult in a position of Donald similar to
that in which Donald Trump finds himself
and we have now growing concern
including even from Kellyanne Conway's
husband George Conway who commented
about this stuff over the weekend we had
a period of several hours over the
weekend where Donald Trump went on a
very unusual even for his standard
spiral of idiocy that has brought
forward even more concerns about the
state of Donald Trump's mental mental
health and and sort of cognitive
abilities first Donald Trump tweeted
about a Saturday Night Live episode that
wasn't even new it was a rerun but
Donald Trump found himself angrily sort
of responding to it on Twitter over the
weekend saying quote it's truly
incredible that shows like Saturday
Night Live not funny
/ no talent can spend all of their time
knocking the same person me over and
over without so much of a mention of the
other side like an advertisement without
consequences same with late-night shows
and of course you know that this is
notable for a couple of different
reasons
the microfocus from this president on
specific shows shows on Fox News
Saturday Night Live Jimmy Kimmel
whoever that's unusual to begin with but
even further it's also not true what
he's saying the late-night shows and
Saturday Night Live will parody
all sorts of different people it may be
that Donald Trump is particularly sort
of thin-skinned and so he's only
impacted by or remembering the critiques
or parodies of himself and then he went
on to attack the late Senator John
McCain who of course passed away of
brain cancer just months ago in a
completely unintelligible tweet but
certainly an attack on John McCain quote
so it was indeed just proven in court
papers quote last in his class
parentheses annapolis john mccain that
sent the quote he capitalized fake
dossier to the FBI and capital m media
hoping to have it printed before the
capital e election he and the Dems
working together failed parentheses as
usual even the capitalized fake news
refused this garbage do you understand
what he's saying here pat is the
criticism that mccain had bad grades
thus his role in forwarding the steel
dossier is to be questioned or something
like that we may have to go over the
tweet a couple more times for me to
fully understand it because i'm just so
lost by the syntax and the erroneous use
of capitalization maybe we can go over
it again yeah i truly don't understand
it and we probably need a full bonus
show actually to figure out what that
one meant but extraordinarily weird then
trump started complaining about the
weekend hosts on fox news also slamming
shepherd smith who as i pointed out
before is basically the lone voice of
reason on fox news during the week you
occasionally then will get chris wallace
saying something remotely intelligible
and logical on weekends Donald Trump
tweeting again the same barrage of
tweets over the weekend were Fox News
weekend anchors arthel neville and
Leland Vitter trained by CNN prior to
their ratings collapse in any event
that's where they should be working
along with their lowest rated anchor
Shepard Smith of course just hours
before this tweet Trump was tweeting
positive things about Fox News go figure
not just yet another one of the
contradicts
and then Trump demanded that that crazy
judge Jeanine Pirro be bought brought
back on the air at Fox News after she
was suspended over some comments that
Fox understood to be Islamophobic he
went on a three tweet rant related to
Jeanine Pirro where he said quote bring
back judge Jeanine Pirro the radical
left Democrats working closely with
their beloved partner the fake news
media is using every trick in the book
to silence a majority of our our capital
C country they have all-out campaigns
against Fox News hosts who are doing too
well Fox must stay strong and fight back
with vigor stop working so hard on being
politically correct which will only
bring you down and continue to fight our
country the losers all want what you
have don't give it to them be strong and
prosper be weak and die stay true to the
people that got you there keep fighting
for tucker and fight by the way Tucker's
fine fighting for tucker and fight hard
for judge Jeanine your competitors are
jealous they all want what you've got
number one don't hand it to them on a
silver platter they can't beat you you
can only beat yourselves it's almost
like if an inspirational speaker lost
all sense of what mattered and how to
speak this is what you would effectively
end up with and it's truly amazing how
much attention Fox News gets from the
president I mean that's that's a
remarkable thing the amount that the
president is watching Fox News the
amount that the president is basing his
public narrative and discourse on
Twitter on what happens to be on Fox
News when he turns it on that he's
making specific programming demands
about bring back Janine and get rid of
Leland Vitter who by the way was the guy
I appeared with when I was on Fox News
very unusual stuff and then at some
point I mean no Trump Twitter rant is
complete without criticizing the Moller
investigation which he did do saying
quote report
Christopher Steele backed up his
Democrat and crooked Hillary paid for
fake and unverified dossier with info
he got from quote send in Watchers
unquote of low rating CNN this is the
info that got us the witch-hunt
and then he went on to reference some
vague insurance policy that he believes
Democrats have against them I think he's
mentioned this before and he calls the
multiple investigations against his
possible crimes an insurance policy he
tweeted quote when the demek what the
Democrats have done in trying to steal a
presidential election first at the
ballot box and then after that failed
with the quote insurance policy is the
biggest capital s scandal in the history
of our capital C country so
understandably many more mental health
professionals expressing concern as a
result of this rant even right-wingers
expressing concern Kellyanne Conway's
husband George Conway saying that
there's a mental condition here that
applies and that it seems to be getting
worse not that surprising given that
just last week Trump was angry with auto
pilot on airplanes raging against
complicated aircraft and I actually I
want to be clear I don't think this is a
funny thing
that we laugh at this is serious it
seems that something is truly sort of
acutely wrong with the President of the
United States and at this point there's
one path out and that's voting in 2020
impeachment might be the right thing and
if it is go ahead and try it but it
would take a long time you need
Republicans to be on board and I don't
think they're going to be removal under
the 25th amendment by the Cabinet
justified at this point good luck making
that a reality
so the if you're sick of this the path
forward is vote the guy out period
because we cannot count on Republicans
to help us remove him that would be
necessary for impeachment that would be
necessary for a removal under the 25th
amendment it's voting in November of
2020 period that is it no matter what
anybody else tells you let me know your
reaction to this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show follow us both and we'll be
right back after this one of today's
sponsors is a company
I'm really excited about because they're
big supporters of progressive media but
it's also a service I've actually been
using for a while in my personal life
it's a language learning service called
linguist and they're letting our
audience try it out for free you don't
even have to enter your credit card
number just go to linguist comm slash
Pakman Ling this was created by one of
the physicists who discovered the Higgs
boson and he designed linguist to help
himself and others learn languages as
efficiently and thoroughly as possible
using artificial intelligence and
machine learning algorithms and that's
what makes Ling this so different from
all of the other language learning apps
out there linguist has used billions of
data points from its learners to figure
out how the human brain actually works
when it's learning a language and
storing memories it mixes new words that
you haven't seen yet with the words you
still need to repeat and the magic
happens when it spaces these repetitions
refreshing a word at just the right
moment so that you don't waste any time
in your learning process it's fast it's
simple there's no fluff no crazy verb
conjugation charts you have to memorize
it's just elegant and proven to be one
of the most efficient ways to learn a
language and it also has voice
recognition capabilities which is super
convenient especially when you're using
the app on your phone go try it on your
browser or mobile device see for
yourself it's available in Spanish
French German and Russian if you're
trying to learn one of these four
languages and you're looking for an
evidence-based method to take your
skills to the next level you should
check it out and you can do it totally
free like I said no credit card required
to try it out
just click the link underneath this
video